je reçois présents jean yves petit
bonsoir le directeur du comité des
yvelines de la prévention routière ce
sont des radars dont nous allons à part
aller selon un bilan du ministère de
l'intérieur le département des yvelines
est le cinquième de france où il crée
pitts le plus quelle est votre réaction
à ce que ça veut dire que les yvelinois
sont des automobilistes peu prudent
alors les yvelinois sont des
automobilistes nombreux déjà puisque les
yvelines c'est le huitième département
le plus peuplé de france nous avons un
million quatre cent mille habitants dont
il ya évidemment beaucoup de passage
beaucoup de voitures dont beaucoup de
flashs qui crépitent certainement
beaucoup trop on va certainement
beaucoup trop vite
mais le fait que nous soyons un
département très peuplées explique
peut-être aussi que nous soyons
malheureusement en tête les marées sont
alors vous vous dites que le travail est
encore est encore long le travail est
encore long et si vous voulez on le
la vitesse reste un fléau en particulier
dans les yvelines
la mortalité et le nombre d'accidents a
baissé de façon assez spectaculaire
depuis le début de l'année par rapport à
l'année précédente
en france mais pas dans les yvelines
dans les idées nous avons au contraire
plus d'accidents et plus de tués que
l'année dernière et une grande partie
liée à la vitesse
donc il ya encore beaucoup de travail à
faire pour faire un premier point sur
saisonnière radar le plus ce reportage
de julie rocha soirée cd le diwan radar
système qui utilise les ondes radio pour
détecter la présence d'objets et
déterminer leur vitesse ou arme anti
chauffard redoutable dans les yvelines
près de 600 mille procès verbaux ont été
établis en 2012
un palmarès record qui nous placent en
cinquième position nationale les flashs
au feu rouge propulse le département sur
la troisième marche derrière les bouches
du rhône et le val de marne de radars
illinois se classe dans le top 100 des
plus actifs en france le plus redoutable
trône le long de la rd 185 avenue des
états-unis à versailles puis de 46000
flash comptabilisé l'année dernière soit
128 crépitements quotidien celui qui les
talonne se situe sur l'autoroute a12 au
niveau de bailly dans le sens trappe
paris 36 1400 flashs enregistrés en 2012
soit 100 par jour
conséquence une progression du nombre de
stagiaires pour la récupération de
points
devenu précieux 80 % des infractions
constatées ces de la vitesse
ensuite devient
le feu rouge qui monte en puissance du à
l'automatisation des contrôles les
foreuses automatique le téléphone on
observe une montée en puissance du
téléphone tenu à la main l'alcool ne
venons que pratiquement en fin de
peloton mais selon ce professionnel
la plupart des excès de vitesse ne
ferait perdre qu'un point la mortalité
sur les routes françaises diminue depuis
quelques années de son trois personnes
ont perdu la vie le mois dernier contre
277 en mars 2012
juste un premier constat auto-écoles
organisateur de stages se fera plutôt
les mains il ya de plus en plus de
stages pour récupérer des points
oui c'est vrai il faut que tout le monde
vive c'est sûr mais le site avait pas de
points récupérés ce sera encore mieux et
c'est le message que vous essayez de
faire passer force et bien sûr bien sûr
notre côté de la prévention routière on
va parler des différentes cabines qui
flashe le fait que la cabine de radars
de versailles par exemple à 50 km/heure
flash soit l'une de celles qui fâchent
d'ailleurs le plus dans le département
ça va être efficace ça va permettre de
sensibiliser on sait cette ville de
versailles et de nombreux accidents et
des accidents mortels et très dramatique
1res allemande exactement d'ailleurs
quelques centaines de mètres après
le radar en question en devant le lycée
hoche il ya deux ans donc
versailles c'est une ville la vitesse
est limitée à 50
ce radar est placé à la sortie par très
loin de la sortie de l'autoroute a13
après les haras de jardy donc les gens
vont encore trop vite dans la descente
c'est ça ça se voit tous les jours mais
ya finalement assez peu de radars en
ville là on comprend bien l'utilité de
ce ratage radars on se dit que ça va
servir à quelque chose mais il ya
d'autres endroits accidentogènes dans
des villes et on ne voit pas de radar
alors un conte km/heure d'abord alors
c'est pas donner ça coûte des sous donc
il faut des sous pour l'installer ça
c'est le préfet qui décide où les radars
doivent être installés en fonction du
budget qu'il a certaines personnes
estime qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus de
radars d'autres qu'il en faudrait
beaucoup moins vous le savez bien
et après ça dépend où les places
suffisamment mais pas forcément au
tournoi absolument manger larmes on
voudrait bien avoir un devant chez soi
pour que les voitures qui sont devant
chez soi l'aï pas trop vite mais tout
ceci doit être est étudiée par les
services de la préfecture et c'est le
préfet qui décide de l'endroit où on
installe vers là pour vous globalement
les radars aujourd'hui sont efficaces
oui oui oui mais enfin j'ai pas que pour
moi c'est les chiffres parlent quand on
installe des radars la la vitesse
diminuer le nombre de tués diminué non
d'accident grave aussi diminue et on
sait très bien qu'à proximité d'un radar
dans une zone où il ya un radar il ya
moins d'accidents tout ça pourquoi quand
on est en ville pour gagner quelques
minutes et se retrouver arrêter de toute
façon au feu rouge suivant ça n'a pas de
sens je veux dire il ya des limitations
de vitesse à respecter
respectons les si vous me permettez
juste un tout petit peu de pédagogie en
une seconde à 50 km heure on parcourt 14
mètres et il faut 27 mètres pour
s'arrêter
la longueur d'une piscine vous imaginez
en ville sur un enfant traverse à
environ 15 mètres ou 20 mètres de vous
vous ne pouvez pas l'éviter à 50
km/heure vous replacer à sa ble ment
vous répéter ces différents messages
vous avez l'impression que ça porte ses
fruits puisque le nombre de flashs a
augmenté c'est pour ça que vous
possèdent les âges c'est bien mais vous
remuer le couteau dans la plaie mais non
il faut y croire et je pense que les
beaucoup de gens qui sont fait flasher
réfléchissent après ils disent mais
effectivement est ce que bon d'avoir ça
coûte des sous quand on attaque au
portefeuille
ça fait toujours mal et puis après c'est
ces radars sont là pour une raison et
comme je viens de vous dire la vitesse à
limiter à 50 en ville elle est
elle est justifiée à 130 sur autoroute
c'est justifié aussi
donc moi je répète effectivement
inlassablement partout où je vais ce
message sur la vitesse mais aussi sur
l'alcool le téléphone en particulier
comme l'avait dit l'expert d'auto école
on a entendu tout à l'heure alors les
radars sont ils efficaces on a entendu
votre point de vue forcément il n'a pas
changé à chaque fois que nous recevons
sur ce plateau et heureusement ceci dit
vous ne changez pas de discours mais on
va voir si les yvelinois les saint
quentinois eux trouvent ces radars
finalement efficace ou non
franchement oui pour entrer pour faire
rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses de
l'état
je trouve ça sert à rien on doit
respecter la vitesse nous mêmes il ya
des panneaux ça suffit maintenant que je
suis un professionnel de la route
ça m'a fait lever le pied par rapport à
avant tout à fait maintenant il ya des
zones à risques qui sont limitées à 110
80 ou 50 où on avait l'habitude de voir
des gens rouler très vite et depuis
qu'il ya des radars bas les gens ne
roule plus aussi vite qu'avant c'est
vrai convient peut vite donc c'est vrai
que ça fait peur donc c'est sûr qu'on a
on freine plus facilement avec les
radars faire des galas peur du radar de
recevoir une amende canton quand on se
fait avoir
justement ça fait prendre conscience que
parfois ben roulait trop vite ça peut
être dangereux
je ralentis parce que sinon je vais
avoir une amende contre moi je le ferai
pas par la banque dit souad ceci dit au
moins la montre d'islande mais ce sont
les interpeller le dernier la dernière
personne ça m'interpelle évidemment
cette personne lève le pied uniquement
par peur du gendarme ou par peur de
l'amande et non pas parce que cette
personne n'a pas pris conscience des
risques qu'elles courent et qu'elle fait
courir aux autres en roulant trop vite
aimé y avoir un changement autour des
radars en tout cas des panneaux de
signalisation alors ça change assez
régulièrement au gré des majorités
puisque les panneaux qui a annoncé ces
radars a été enlevé ils vont finalement
être installé un nouveau pour prévenir
de la présence de ces radars c'est
officiel un décret c'était à compter du
c'était à compter pardon je tombe de
date ce sera très prochainement mis en
place mais il ya eu ce décret qui est
qui est passé mais pas nous reviennent
non non moi ça me gêne pas qu'ils
reviennent d'abord ça sort pas comme ça
du chapeau 1
il ya le conseil national de la sécurité
routière qui a travaillé dessus et qui
avait vidé des recommandations et le
délégué interministériel à la sécurité
routière et l'ancien directeur de
général de la police nationale du temps
du président sarkozy donc cyrus est pas
une histoire politique
c'est une histoire d'efficacité ceci dit
quand les panneaux ont été enlevés ou
nous a aussi expliqué que c'était mieux
de les enlever parce que comme ça les
gens ne freinez plus à la dernière nuit
c'est vrai c'est voilà c'est vrai mais
après il faut étudier ça dans la durée
et on voit dans la durée si la solution
qui a été proposée est bonne ou pas tout
ceci ne peut s'étudier que à partir de
dudu dote d'un certain temps avec des
chiffres pour pour vraiment voir si
c'est efficace ou pas autre décret celui
ci les dater du 1er mars c'est le décret
qui supprime la sanction qui devait
s'appliquer en cas de non possession de
d'éthylotests le fait que les
éthylotests aujourd'hui ne soit en tout
cas soit fortement conseillée mais pas
ce soit pas sanctionnable alors c'est
exactement le même sujet que dont nous
parlions à l'instant sur les allers
retours
ces éthylotests avaient été rendues
obligatoires par un décret de février
et ils sont aujourd'hui toujours
obligatoire c'est à dire que le décret
de février 2012 n'a pas été encore
abrogé mais ce sera pas sanctionné mais
les ministères qui se sont succédé ont
repoussé la date de la sanction est
aujourd'hui elle est repoussée signer
dié et le conseil national de la
sécurité routière a recommandé de faire
laisse comme je viens de le dire à
l'instant une évaluation du dispositif
est-ce que l'éthylotest obligatoire en
voiture est utile ou pas s'il n'est pas
utile le délégué interministériel à la
sécurité routière proposera que le
décret soit rapporter tout simplement
pour vous pour la prévention routière
est ce que c'est nécessaire ou non que
ce soit sanctionné quel est votre point
de non non non moi ça m'est égal que ce
soit sanctionné ou pas c'est pas mon
problème
ce que je veux c'est que les gens
comprennent que ce petit objet doit être
devrait être un objet d' usage courant
et qu'il est pour eux et c'est un acte
volontaire
c'est à dire que la personne qui
estiment qu'elle est peut-être un peu
limite
elle souffle dans le ballon et elle
regarde où elle en est et après elle est
face à ses responsabilités
personne ne viendra lui dire qu'elle n'a
pas le droit de conduire
après elle se fait arrêter par la police
elle est en tort où elle est pas encore
mais la personne aura pris ses
responsabilités si elle a fait la
démarche de souffler dans le ballon elle
même
alcool vitesse on parle prévention
routière sécurité routière ce soir les
vacances approchent un encore encore
quelques jours a donc une nouvelle fois
les enfants soit en vacances et qu'il y
encore de pas mal de monde sur les sur
les routes
quelques conseils à donner encore des
vacances oui vous avez raison pile avec
le bouton alors des conseils à donner
encore un petit mot de pédagogie vous
savez que l'on à un accident seul il n'y
a pas besoin de plusieurs véhicules
la plupart des accidents impliquant un
seul véhicule que ce soit une moto ou un
ou une voiture et on a un accident quand
il fait beau
parce que quand il fait mauvais d'abord
il ya moins de véhicules qui circulent
et en particulier - de route on est
beaucoup plus vigilants quand il fait
beau je regardais tout à l'heure en
attendant
de passer sur votre plateau le spot de
la sécurité routière que vous avez remis
avec le motard qui est très vigilant en
ville dès qu'ils arrivent à la campagne
les petits oiseaux c'est l'été il fait
beau il accélère et ans l'entente
l'accident qui survient donc les
accidents interviennent quand on est
seul et quand il fait beau et à la
proche des vacances c'était le message
que je voulais passer puisque jean des
livres assez souvent chez vous et je
vous en remercie
aujourd'hui je voulais indiqué celui ci
méfiez-vous vigilance quand il fait beau
il faut rester vigilant et puis nous
reste juste quelques instants alors pour
conclure je voudrais juste parler de
cette opération et que vous menez à
oudon ce sera le 1er juin avec une
classe de cm2 challenge départemental
pour les enfants ça consistera à voir
alors tout au long de l'année nos
bénévoles interviennent dans les écoles
primaires du département dans les
classes de cm2 pour
enseigner aux enfants en particulier le
vélo cm2 c'est l'âge auquel et commencé
à faire du vélo et à la fin de l'année
scolaire
nous organisons un challenge pour faire
concourir le meilleur élève de chaque
cm2 qui est passé entre nos mains c'est
pas tous les cm2 du département loin de
là cette année ce challenge a lieu le
samedi 1er juin à houdan c'est
l'occasion pour les enfants de concourir
bien sûr et pour leurs parents de tester
fin de de voir nos différents
simulateurs de conduite alcool etc et
chez l'occasion d'une petite fête de la
prévention routière à laquelle tous les
yvelinois et les départements
limitrophes sont évidemment
chaleureusement conviés à sensibiliser
les parents par l'intermédiaire des
enfants de ce moment ça marche toujours
bien merci jean yves petit directeur du
comité d'éveil de la prévention routière
mais pour fermer cette séquence puisque
nous parlions de vitesse aussi de départ
en vacances de printemps qui vont
débuter dans une semaine voici une
petite vidéo de la prévention routière
une vidéo qui rappelle certaines
obligations qui donne aussi quelques
conseils de bon sens
les bons réflexes autoroute adapter sa
vitesse sur l'autoroute covire respecter
les vitesses réglementaires et si
nécessaire
adaptez votre vitesse au trafic et aux
conditions météo
petit rappel des règles en la matière à
vos chiffres partez en pratique par
temps sec et avec une bonne visibilité
la vitesse maximale autorisée est de 130
kilomètres heure la vitesse est réduite
à 110 km/heure dans certaines zones et
partout en cas de pluie et de faibles
brouillard et si la visibilité est
inférieure à 50 mètres
réduisez la à 50 km heure enfin
n'oubliez pas de respecter la vitesse
maximum autorisée indiquées sur les
panneaux de signalisation aux abords des
chantiers et à la proche des péages
concrètement pourquoi c'est si important
tout simplement parce que suivre ses
conseils c'est préserver sa sécurité
celle des autres automobilistes et
favoriser une circulation fluide en plus
comme vous consommez moins d'essence
vous faites des économies et un geste
pour l'environnement
ensemble adoptant les bons réflexes pour
une autoroute encore plus sûres